the second animation the second hentai
you recommended was ah
yeah you cannot tell me this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] off
this premise is a [ __ ] bad i don't
know i've read the original source i've
read the original source material
and i [ __ ] hate it that queen bee got
this [ __ ] source material because
queen bee get the best source material
but i'm basically using the doji with
extra steps when it's animated by queen
yeah because because the problem with
queen bee right is that they are premium
hentai click bait
because they have like the best stills
and you see you see the thumbnail as
you're scrolling down you're like
yo this looks [ __ ] hot and then you
see them moving and it's just like
instant
instant softy and it's literally just
like them taking the dough and doing
this
yeah it's it's like it sucks it's like
they [ __ ] learns how to use like the
warp tool in photoshop
and also like the [ __ ] vegas like
keyframing tool yeah
those like the two the two tools i will
not lie it does sometimes pop me off
when i see a blatant shitty keyframe
like that that's annoying yeah but damn
if their plots ain't good man yeah god
damn they're what their plots are god
damn and the character design is [ __ ]
hot
yeah yeah yeah so should i explain the
plot as i remember it
yes correct me if i get anything wrong
basically it's uh two girls
uh you know so not not too many to keep
track of yeah yeah
and it's summer break clash not summer
break something like that and the dad is
never at home conveniently
yeah yeah and and they [ __ ] and one of
one of the girls is like super horny and
always wants to [ __ ]
and one of the girls just wants to watch
for some reason yeah i don't get that
and then the shy girl kind of like gets
us like oh i'm interested in sex
yeah yeah and then the shy girl is like
yeah yeah hell yeah dude the shy girl's
hot as [ __ ]
dude yeah and then they just start you
know they okay it's just it's it's very
it's
it's okay they don't miss this is like
except the end when they like
run off together that was weird i was
like i was like whoa whoa whoa come on
the thing i noticed about all the stuff
that you like is
it's basically just live-action porn
animated
it's just it's just it's just like it's
just your typical [ __ ]
pornhub video except it's hentai but the
thing is right is that when it's like on
pornhub
these people look [ __ ] weird or
disgusting half the time
and i don't i don't want to you know
what i mean yeah
and it's nice seeing like you know just
[ __ ] like
i don't know just normal people it's
nice not seeing an ugly bastard just say
it yeah it's nice not seeing
it's nice seeing someone who i could be
like that's that could be me
if i was a lucky [ __ ] you know
and like
you're watching it you know also it's
got everything that i like man
straight up like and you know public sex
is hot in shows it's dangerous man it's
dangerous got a little danger going on
they [ __ ] behind they're saying that
they're saying that through experience
or well i i don't comment on those kind
of things jay
um there's also like what is the one
that came out recently uh
the succubus one what it was like which
is why i'm
surprised you didn't recognize that one
i didn't pick that because that was that
was by a good animation studio yeah
because i thought i didn't pick that
because i thought that was too easy it's
too high quality
because i thought we would agree on that
because because the thing is i actually
noticed that it's a better version i
actually noticed
i actually learned this down which is
like why did connor not pick stuck about
state life which is by the same
author and artist that's dude they're
both the same artists that is like
amazing that's god tier yeah that that's
up there to me with like masterpiece
that is what that is better than the
masterpiece because that's good it has
good animation
to disagree but the point was is that
like dude because the scene in
in that that uh succubus wasn't the
second state huh sucka stayed life
like that that [ __ ] scene when they
[ __ ] in the hallway that's hard as [ __ ]
dude
is it not come on come on is it not it
is it cause you're like yo we got like
30 seconds to wrap this up let's do it
and it's harder the quickest nut in the
world that's what's hard about it man
cause you're like yo the danger i know
they're not gonna get caught
but it could be it could yeah and like
what i love about a lot of the character
designs that queen bee happened to
choose is that all the girls
they're like they have a bit of meat on
them yeah yeah yeah you see like
a lot of anime girl designs especially
in hentai
and it's just like typical here i am
anorexic yeah
i want a little chunk to them yeah yeah
yeah it's rare that you get to see any
like meat anyway stuff like breasts yeah
and [ __ ] in [ __ ]
i also appreciate how almost 99 of the
time they do maintain the original
artists
yeah yeah and that's that that's
probably something
that's probably the problem you're
saying i have good taste it's literally
scene for scene
but just with
is fantastic the source material is
fantastic queen bee
hell no hell no
out of here like is it are you putting
the the animation
and all of that it is as important as
important i i mean
if animation isn't as important then why
am i not reading the [ __ ] dojin [ __ ]
if i cared about animation right i would
just watch real life porn cause that
[ __ ] that's one-to-one perfect animation
you know what i mean
like porn and hentai are nothing alike
you know
where there's no plot or no story or no
like [ __ ] like premise
it's just it's animation that's all it
is that's like saying
i would rather watch the live-action
adaptation of an anime rather than the
[ __ ]
anime uh no no